some Palestinian families radio is the
only way they can connect to their loved
ones in Israeli prisons
Palestinian prisoners tune in and listen
to their families sharing news and
updates shows like this one on the voice
of Palestine radio are even more
important for prisoners whose families
are not allowed to visit
Yasser Hamid speaks on the radio she
tells her two sons she's doing well and
can't wait to see them
for years the Israeli authorities
haven't allowed Mr to visit her children
citing grounds of security
Israel controls who gets to visit
Palestinian families need permits to
cross into Israel where almost all the
jails are
yester lives alone now she says holiday
periods are the hardest time of the year
I worry about them do they eat well do
they get enough food do they like it is
it too cold in jail
is accused of shooting and killing an
Israeli settler in 2015. he's yet to be
sentenced her youngest Norman has been
held for more than a year in what's
called administrative detention
imprisonment without charges both Moab
and Norman have been jailed before
they keep saying they have a secret file
why don't they tell us what he's being
held for it's because they have nothing
on him it's just an excuse to keep him
in jail
says it's almost impossible for
prisoners with administrative detention
to plan their lives
no man spent more than two years in
administrative detention before and
after his release he decided to get
engaged and start a family he was
arrested shortly after and held under
administrative detention again he's
still in jail for over a year now
currently there are 4 800 prisoners in
Israeli jails nearly 1 000 are in
administrative detention human rights
groups say this is the highest number of
administrative detines in two decades
this protest takes place every week to
demand the release of prisoners over the
years the numbers of those taking part
has been declining
if there is an imminent danger facing
Prisoners the people will take to the
streets just recently prisoners were to
start the hunger strike people ready for
a confrontation this is why Israel caved
into the demands of prisoners it knows
that the tensions would have escalated
on the streets so they backtracked
prisoners to know that they won't be
released in any deal soon but most live
in hope that one day they'll be reunited
with their families
the occupied West Bank